monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues au nom des députés du groupe
modem et démocrate apparenté
je veux exprimer la colère et l'émotion
qui nous saisit ce matin avec les
nouvelles qui nous proviennent de notre
dame de nice est adressé aux familles
des victimes à leurs proches aux niçois
nos pensées amicales et fraternelles
mesdames messieurs et miss vous voici ce
matin devant la représentation nationale
pour soumettre à son approbation
l'une des décisions les plus graves dont
elle ait jamais eu à débattre
il ya six mois nous entrions en guerre
contre cet ennemi invisible
cet ennemi venu de loin qui mit en
quelques semaines la planète à genoux
nous consentions une première fois à
nous priver de nos libertés a fermé nos
écoles à nous séparer de nos proches
pour échapper à cette vague emportant
tout sur son passage
nous applaudissions ne soignant et nous
comptions nos morts mais nous avons
résisté nous avons tenu et nous avons
cultiver l'espoir que le pire était
désormais derrière nous que nous
pourrions faire face en attendant un
traitement ou avec ça mais voici que
l'europe toute entière est en proie avec
une funeste réplique avec une nouvelle
déferlante aussi violente qu'inattendue
et voici la france et son gouvernement
placé devant un défi immense celui de
protéger les français tout en assurant
la continuité économique social et
politique de la nation sur cette ligne
de crête
le président de la république a fait le
seul choix qui s'imposait et à la vérité
le seul choix qu'il nous reste celui du
rpt confinement ayons la lucidité de
partager son constat à la lumière de
l'aggravation exponentielle de
l'épidémie ayons l'humilité de
reconnaître qu'il n'ya pas de solution
miracle
le président en a fait hier la
démonstration imparable nos capacités de
réanimation arrive à saturation et ni un
confinement sélectif ni la meilleure
stratégie de test du monde ne suffirait
et ne résoudrait rien nous devons donc
être à la hauteur de notre
responsabilité
alors que tant de vies humaines sont en
jeu au pays de l'humanisme des lumières
on ne transige pas avec la vie humaine
vous nous avez présenté la façon dont
vous entendez mettre en oeuvre ce
confinement et les députés du groupe
modem et démocrate apparenté on approuve
les grands principes celui de la
généralité pour que la règle soit
comprises pour que les français y
consentent
elle doit être la même part
tout un versailles comme à bordeaux est
appliquée avec équité celui de la
continuité continuité économique
continuité pédagogique les écoles
restent ouverts le travail continue
grâce au maintien des dispositifs de
soutien nous ne rendons pas les armes et
le pays avance celui de la réactivité
enfin et de l'adaptation du dispositif
au fil de l'eau pendant les cinq
semaines qui nous séparent du 1er
décembre
vous avez souhaité présenter les
contours et le détail de ces mesures au
parlement et solliciter son vote
nous saluons cette initiative comme le
veut la constitution le parlement vote
les lois ils contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et évalue les politiques
publiques et l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas manqué à son devoir depuis le début
de la crise les députés se sont
pleinement mobilisées pour amender et
voter les textes d'urgence pour
habiliter le gouvernement à légiférer
par ordonnances parfois mais pour
contrôler son action toujours pour
veiller à ce que les mesures de soutien
soit appliquée dans leur circonscription
et pour faire remonter les difficultés
rencontrées et nous continuerons de le
faire jusqu'au bout car nous ne
gagnerons cette guerre qu'à condition
que le peuple français il soit associé à
travers ses représentants alors alors
vous allez voir défiler à cette tribune
sur les réseaux sociaux sur les chaînes
d'information en continu vous allez voir
défiler le long cortège des critiques
avisées des procureurs en verve des
professionnels de la profession et des
faux prophètes se perdre dans de vains
réquisitoire ceci mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
s'ils se diviseront en quatre catégories
également répartie il ya ceux qui vous
diront que si nous en sommes là c'est
que vous n'avez pas tiré les leçons de
la crise du printemps
si nos gouvernants ne s'était pas tourné
les pouces sous les plafonds dorés de la
république nous aurions retrouver les
jours meilleurs et tout irait mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes
un grand classique de littérature c'est
nier l'évidence
c'est oublier de regarder ce qu'il se
passe au delà de nos frontières
toute l'europe
l'allemagne air soirée contrainte au
repli face au tsunami qui menace et
hôpitaux c'est d'oublier que la deuxième
vague est fondamentalement différente de
la première en ce qu'elle touche toute
la france en même temps c'est
méconnaître la réalité des faits notre
capacité de test a été décuplé notre
capacité de réanimation va doubler pas
par miracle non mais bien parce que les
administrations ont mis tout en oeuvre
pour y parvenir
alors oui il est tentant de se refaire
une santé médiatique ou politique sur
leur dos mais c'est irresponsable
il y a ceux qui vous diront il ya ceux
qui vous diront que vous en faites trop
qu'après tôt nous avons appris à vivre
avec le virus à porter le masque à
aménager nos espaces de travail nos
salles de restaurant qu'il faut nous
laisser vivre ce gouvernement va-t-il
cesser enfin d'emmerder les français le
président de la république l'a rappelé
très clairement hier toutes ces
précautions ne suffisent plus alors que
l'épidémie s'emballe nous devons donner
un coup de frein brutal pour éviter la
sortie de route
mais il a réaffirmé avec force que
personne ne sera laissé au bord du
chemin
grâce au maintien de l'activité
partielle du fonds de solidarité des
prêts garantis par l'état qui ont
préservé et millions de français des
millions d'entreprises et qui
continueront de le faire il faut avoir
l'honnêteté de le reconnaître il y as eu
et c'est la troisième catégorie qui vous
diront que vous n'en fait pas assez que
le virus est devenu beaucoup plus
dangereux après l'avoir été moins après
l'avoir été plus et que tout cela est
évident et que le gouvernement devrait
le savoir mais qu'ils n'écoutent rien
qu'il eût fallu fermer les lycées où les
entreprises ou les maisons de retraite
mais tout cela eût été impensable
voulons nous contraindre une nouvelle
fois alignement nos personnes âgées ou
dépendantes voulons nous sacrifier une
génération d'étudiants déjà durement
éprouvé par la crise voulons-nous
renoncer à travailler à créer à
entreprendre
non il faut avoir le courage de le dire
la quatrième catégorie des critiques
c'est celle de ceux qui ne trouvent pas
grand chose à dire mais qui ont comme
l'envié irrésistible d'alimenter la
polémique
ils vous diront que vous piétinez le
parlement que vous n'auriez même pas dû
solliciter son vote ou alors si mais la
veille ou le lendemain ou une autre fois
où toutes les semaines
la vérité c'est que tout cela n'est que
vanité que tout cela est bien loin de ce
qui doit nous occuper aujourd'hui et
dans les semaines qui viennent ce qui
doit nous occuper mes chers collègues
c'est la solidarité et la responsabilité
solidarité d'abord avec les plus
fragiles les plus modestes les plus
petits ce sont eux qui prennent la crise
de plein fouet le président de la
république l'a rappelé hier ils risquent
plus que d'autres d'être touchées par la
maladie il risque plus que d'autres de
décrocher de basculer dans la précarité
et la misère assez indépendant qui
pointe pour la première fois au rsa à
ses étudiants qui ne trouvent pas de
petits boulots à ces familles
monoparentales à ces jeunes de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
nous devrons trouver des solutions si
les annonces que vous avez fait la
semaine dernière mesdames et messieurs
les milices ne devrait pas suffire
nous devrons les compléter n'oublions
pas non plus la jeunesse qui est au
coeur du plan de relance et qui doit
rester au coeur de nos préoccupations
il faut que tout soit mis en oeuvre pour
que chaque jeune est accès à une
formation ou un emploi et puisse ainsi
sereinement envisager l'avenir
solidarité aussi avec les associations
les entreprises les commerçants les
restaurateurs les artistes comme le
virus se propage au travers de nos
relations sociales les difficultés qu
impose le confinement aux entreprises
fermées administrativement se
propageront à l'ensemble de l'économie
avec les difficultés de trésorerie
d'abord qui se diffuseront par
l'intermédiaire des retards des défauts
de paiements des défaillances
d'entreprises avec la baisse de la
demande et les ruptures
d'approvisionnement avec en somme le
risque majeur que se dégrade le
patrimoine culturel et entrepreneuriale
de la france une entreprise qui
disparaît c'est un tissu de relations
c'est un savoir faire c'est une
communauté humaine qui sont perdus un
commerce qui ferme c'est la vie c'est
l'âme d'un village qui s'éteint
nos entreprises nos commerces et nos
artisans sont un trésor national qu'il
est de notre devoir de protéger
quoi qu'il en coûte les dispositifs mis
en oeuvre au printemps ont fait leurs
preuves et doivent être amplifiées les
100 millions d'euros du plan de relance
donneront des perspectives aux
collectivités aux entreprises qui ont
déjà massivement répondu au premier
appel à projets mais il faudra aller
plus loin accompagner la mutation la
digitalisation des modèles économiques
pour tenir compte de l'évolution des
comportements de nos concitoyens traiter
la question centrale des loyers assurer
l'équité de traitement entre le petit
commerce la grande distribution
les géants du numérique les députés
démocrates ont fait des propositions en
ce sens que nous vous invitons mesdames
et messieurs les ministres à mettre en
oeuvre sans attendre solidarité avec les
soignants
c'est la moindre des choses que la
france confiné puisse faire pour les
héros les super héros qui se battent
pour elle médecins infirmiers
ambulanciers aide soignant auxiliaire de
vie
brancardier pharmaciens toutes ces
blouses blanches qui se sont illustrés
au printemps par leur bravoure qui ont
accumulé une immense fatigue et que
voilà reparti sur la première ligne du
front qui doivent parfois à contre coeur
des programmes et des opérations
pourtant vital pour leurs patients
ils sont la grandeur de la france et
notre gratitude envers eux est
inépuisable
au nom du groupe modem
je veux saluer la concrétisation des
accords du ségur de la santé dans le
plfss pour 2021 qui viennent revaloriser
leur rémunération et redonner des marges
de manoeuvre à l'hôpital sans doute
faudra-t-il aller plus loin pour leur
témoigner de notre pleine reconnaissance
la solidarité est une condition
nécessaire mais elle n'est pas
suffisante car ce qui est en jeu dans
cette épreuve redoutable c'est la
vitalité de notre démocratie et la
solidité de notre socle républicain
encore brutalisé ce matin à nice et nous
sommes donc appelés individuellement et
collectivement à la responsabilité
notre responsabilité première c'est de
faire reculer l'épidémie en respectant
scrupuleusement
dans les gestes barrières les règles du
confinement en téléchargeant tous
antique au vide sur son téléphone que
ceux qui l'ont téléchargée lève la main
chacun doit être acteur de la bataille
que nous livrons ensemble contre le
virus
et dans ce combat que nous menons en
commun nous avons la responsabilité les
uns des autres
tout en respectant les consignes
sanitaires chacun peut aussi apporter
sanitaires
chacun peut aussi à porter secours et
assistance
un voisin isolé à une famille dans le
besoin
je forme le voeu que l'esprit de
fraternité que l'esprit de fraternité
qui a germé au printemps nous aident à
traverser ensemble cet automne re
confiné notre responsabilité collective
c'est de garantir la continuité de nos
institutions dans un moment où nous
restreignons les libertés individuelles
comme rarement nous l'avons fait dans
l'histoire au moment où la nation et
frappaient en plein coeur par le
terrorisme islamiste
nous ne saurions nous habituer car nous
chérissons la liberté en france plus que
partout ailleurs
la situation exige que le pouvoir soit
partagé car sinon le pouvoir sera
confisquée par les réseaux sociaux par
les complotistes en tous genres qui sape
la confiance et fragilise la démocratie
cela suppose je les dis que le parlement
soit associé aux décisions que vous
prendrez mesdames et messieurs les
ministres et à travers lui le peuple
français
cela suppose aussi que les français
n'est pas à choisir entre leur santé et
l'exercice de leurs droits civiques
le moment n'est-il pas venu de nous
doter d'un système de vote pleinement
opérationnel en temps de crise en moins
d'une semaine
70 millions d'américains ont voté par
correspondance après l'abstention record
constaté lors des précédents scrutins
nous devons maintenant réagir depuis la
toute première heure les démocrates
défendre l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de
démocratie sans que la conscience et la
responsabilité soient poussés à leur
maximum
nous continuerons à défendre cette idée
notre responsabilité enfin c'est de ne
pas renoncer
c'est de ne pas nous décourager à
préparer le jour d'après invitant
l'europe à faire la renaissance emmanuel
mounier disait qu'il ne faut guère
compter sur les époques satisfaites et
que les crises seul
rappel la plupart à la méditation il
avait raison et au travers des ténèbres
où nous voici plongés pointe une lueur
d'espoir l'espoir qu'un autre monde
puisse émerger des ruines du précédent
un monde plus sûr
un monde plus fraternel un monde plus
juste
une europe plus indépendante et plus
protectrice une place repensé pour
l'homme dans son environnement
un modèle de développement dans lequel
l'intérêt privé c'est toujours devant
l'intérêt général et la préservation des
biens communs une association toujours
plus large des salariés des travailleurs
au partage de la valeur et à la
gouvernance des entreprises
une égalité de fait entre les femmes et
les hommes une femme une france dans
laquelle chacun puisse se réapproprier
son destin une france plus frotte forte
prête à affronter les grandes crises
comme celle que nous vivons aujourd'hui
vous l'avez compris mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues le groupe mouvement
démocrate et démocrate apparenté
soutient la politique que vous entendez
mené en nous appelant collectivement à
la solidarité et à la responsabilité
merci monsieur barreaux